unprofessional doctors run at the sight
of ugliness their child was born
different therefore the sensible thing
was to raise him in a tiny cage I mean
of course right Paul Reubens almost
certainly shot this cameo prior to his
actual porno theater arrest but still
porno theater arrests and all that that
implies
JonBenet Ramsey also Bizzaro Moses's mom
over two and a half minutes of floating
baby carriage credits sudden bat show up
for no reason other than a mad
convergence of coincidental harmony DC
Comics the penguin will become the
penguin via a story not unlike the
jungle book also for some reason Gotham
has penguins living beneath its streets
because that makes sense also on how the
the Penguins take care of a human baby
can their beaks change diapers
48 and DeVito years also 33 years is
pretty specific why not just 30 do we
really give it what exact age that
penguin baby grows up to be in this film
was some writer just trying to get cute
by being too specific with the length of
the time jump also Gotham City looks
exactly the covers of those 1960s
science fiction novels that your older
brothers drew an entire animated stick
figure kung-fu flip book through that
was more interesting in the book itself
this tree lighting ceremony in a city
with tens of millions of citizens has
attracted approximately 47 people
Lily unintentionally inspires the Joel
Schumacher Batman movies where the fuck
is the sewer the penguin could get this
good a look at the Christmas tree I'll
tell you for a fact there isn't one
because it looks fake it also this movie
came out June 19 1992
back then people craved Christmas movies
in the summer cosmic fate allows for
this pan up from the villains straight
to Alfred Chuck they try to make
Michelle Pfeiffer look all frumpy but it
comes off as dishonest as she's all that
that's the point of a giant cat ornament
on the side of your building that tells
time but has no numbers on it hey Bill
what time is it um it's right about
eyebrow right incisor o'clock really
oh so almost seven then when you let Tim
Burton direct his true vision you end up
with lavish sets and two fits the extras
you need we welcome please Gotham's own
Santa Claus Max Schreck
with absolutely no subtlety whatsoever
Batman Returns names one of its villains
after the actor who famously played
Nosferatu
- one letter o dine how about someone
this ditzy ever get this job in the
first place I actually think there are
more microphones in attendance than
spectators we want the big guy the guy
who runs the show what do you want now
you right why not just ask for Shrek in
the first place not go so how does the
bat-signal tell him where to go though
was he using police scanners at this
point cuz if so wouldn't monitoring
police scanners have told him about the
situation before the bat-signal did I
think it would have when two people were
shooting a Batman from the hood of his
Batmobile his best option is to brake
suddenly I hope there's a fire around
straight-up murder thanks for saving the
day Batman he did all they did was take
out four guys did we miss all the
ass-kicking on the hundreds of other bad
guys who are running around Mac's
decided to stand on a sewer grate for
some reason most people avoid standing
or walking on them because they mistrust
the government but Mac's actually stands
on them proudly and you see what happens
I want to find out who I am by finding
my parents how did you learn English was
it that teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle way
the Penguins didn't teach you did they a
lot of tape and a little patience make
all that difference I don't doubt you
taped all the incriminating documents
back because they did that for real an
Argo but how did you know such documents
would be incriminating how many
documents does a company like Shrek
destroy every day how did you know you
were piecing back together yesterday's
lunch menu
I forgot not married will be constantly
hammers home how pathetic Selina Kyle is
as if the studio had said no one's gonna
believe Michelle Pfeiffer is this much
of a loser she's gonna have to remind
everyone in every scene but then people
will believe it getting cats milk is a
bad idea if you only remember one thing
from the sins video I hope it's don't
give milk to cats also this is the
apartment of two's - tea pots on the
stove - tea cups awaiting tea on the
counter - toys on the doggy bed - steps
to get up to the counter - tomatoes in
the window where is the second cat
already Selina about that Christmas
getaway we planned wait you mean there's
actually a man in her life who she's
actually excited about
she just doesn't acknowledge him until
the answering machine message drives
home even more pathetic miss also can
someone transport me to a world where
all the guys turned down Michelle
Pfeiffer and I even opened the protected
files I know she's supposed to be a ditz
of some sort but why in the hell would
she ever think it's a good idea to open
protected files I figured your password
was Geraldo your Chihuahua and it was if
you've done this to Sarah Palin your ass
would be in jail right now
what did curiosity do to the cat
pre-emptive punter ewwww I know it's
late at night but that's gonna go
unnoticed
seriously I'm like Oh every other murder
victim ever cats will inexplicably race
to this woman's rescue and lick her
wounds with nourishing cat saliva
somehow matter in the grand scheme of
things and maybe even keep her alive
what the actual by the way what you're
seeing here is the extremely dark
version of the makeover from she's all
that it's amazing these cats even helped
her after all the abuse she's giving
them feeding the milk throwing them on
the floor just what did she do to
deserve superpowers there's no way any
disposal would work with that many damn
stuffed animals clogging up the sink
Selina took the time to deface her own
dollhouse instead of just becoming
Catwoman already with the unbelievab
ility factor higher than most Batman's
at this point it's amazing Selina can't
call on her cat army to sew this costume
for all so why is this the first thing
you think to do when you've been revived
from the dead and now you have powers
you know what gotta need a costume just
the way it is the Gotham City in this
movie is the most uncomfortably small
city ever made and it's way too
obviously a set in the last movie even
though they kept using the same theater
in the background over and over it felt
a lot bigger than Whoville mom doesn't
seem all that upset that some asshole
just took her baby this plan entirely
relies on a crowd to be completely quiet
after a baby just got stolen and hoped
that no one will try and play hero and
jump down in the sewer to chase the guy
also because no one here is an actual
detective no one will wonder how the
sewer grating was left completely open
for the kidnapper to chameleons jump
down into to make us a skate and how
penguin just happened to be there to
stop it somehow despite the fact that
this duck is the thing that elevates
penguin to the surface he will emerge
with no duck in sight even as he
continues to be elevated out of the
sewer because let's face it there was no
way that duck was getting through that
opening what I'm saying is this
downright impossible yo was born a
little different in a nutshell penguin
describes all Tim Burton movies see all
these bats roaming free I wonder what
happened to that one caged bat Bruce
held hostage during the last movie
nearly all the paragraphs on this
newspaper except the first one
underneath the headline about the circus
is a bunch of bull also while I may be
too lazy or busy to find them all you
can rest assure that each and every one
of this movie's close-up newspaper shots
has some glaring inaccuracy I was the
number one son and they treated me like
number two all right I guess you weren't
expecting a Pujo can Batman but there
you go
he's like a frog but became a friend
nice more like a big one this extra
would be excellent at cinemasins
I'm glad Catwoman is here to save this
chick but how did she beat Batman here
and wait Batman never even shows up in
the scene the hell I first Todd I mean
one overlooked aspect of cat behavior is
their ability to come food I'd offer you
coffee but my assistant is using a
vacation time we didn't bother to
replace her during vacation time so
actually no one is getting coffee the
next two weeks regardless of who they
are Bruce and track agreed to see each
other as long as Bruce got to conduct
the meeting at a comically hilarious
distance away from Max I mean it's as
simple as how many times you see the sky
in this movie you know how movies set in
New York find a way to show you a sky
every now and then Gotham has no sky and
I can practically see The Fresh Prince
of bel-air getting taped in the
background this idiots master plan is to
somehow get Cobblepot a grunting
grotesque flipper having raw fish
devouring mass of a creature elected
mayor this idiot is an idiot movie
unintentionally inspires Mike Tyson
Oswald Cobblepot boy I like to fill a
void this doesn't even feel like a
Batman movie now he threw a gross sexual
innuendo in this with only a fraction of
action so far this movie isn't Batman
it's Edward Scissorhands reimagined by
Danny DeVito stop global warming start
global cooling make the world a giant
icebox we didn't send Batman and Robin
for mr. freeze copying the Penguins
exact same plan so we will send it
retroactively Lee in this movie
how many villainous plots are going to
revolve around freezing everything this
dog is going to carry a grenade to a
store in order for it to blow up but why
using a dog in this way offers no
advantages in stealth or execution and
don't you put the dog in danger and how
does it grenade have that kind of delay
on ant-man just stood there while this
dude got harassed if you have scanning
technology that is this amazing then why
not use that on all weapons and end
these things in three seconds by the way
what the book is the Shrek company have
to do with cats michelle pfeiffer ends
the lives of two potential mates for
Andrew McCarthy this is just a truly be
Batman movie and it's way worse than we
even remember it there's virtually no
room for Catwoman in this thing she's
just there and pointless it's the
patient zero of too many villain
syndrome even the Gotham Wilhelm's had
their plight committed to celluloid
but Batman doesn't kill though right I
mean that dude dead you don't really
think you'll win to you in the fight
between the two of us right now or in a
game of Scrabble by the way I think the
answer is yes I saw first gotta fly
penguin with absolutely no proof of
wrongdoing makes a villainous exit from
the scene for no reason and he says I
saw her first like he's gonna chase
after Catwoman
but now he's just gone this contraction
defies all logic and I mean all logic
what is this great Batman's climbing a
ladder with an obvious steep drop behind
him but he lands on a roof but the mine
how could you I'm a woman
Batman falls for this whatever that is
throws Catwoman into a thing that was
previously nowhere near this
whatchamacallit
now that man let's go when he easily
lands on something not that far below it
that means the dire situation Batman was
in in the beginning of the scene wasn't
nearly as dire and he didn't even need
to throw that blue glowing thing a
Catwoman and how did Batman get on this
completely other building above Catwoman
after falling down another one to save
her I don't know and you don't either
quiet Batman topologist in the back this
makes no sense it's almost as if you
have 9o also Wow what a fortuitous kitty
litter truck those things drive around
24 hours a day just the pussy have him
working ah who's responsible for this
awful penguin horniness
why hasn't Shrek bought this guy some
hookers yet do we really need James Bond
double entendres in a Batman movie wait
I disassembled his Batmobile and turn it
into an h-bomb on wheels
never mind the specifics of how we'll do
that or how we even got these blueprints
in the first place just shut up and
follow the script damn it he'd have even
more power as a martyr what yet again
Batman villains don't want to kill
Batman because of stupid reasons
swallowing the bird hole was creepy and
effective but isn't remotely close to
what real cats do with real birds also
and on the same subject movie contains
no scenes of Catwoman sneaking into her
owners bedroom and dropping off a bird
head first of all why would you put your
TV this close to the goddamn fire won't
it melt soon did the cat woman even make
the news last night she blew something
up with Batman a block away mind you
then seduce the penguin in closed
quarters why the fuck is she front-page
news and all the papers and why does
Gotham have so many gone down newspapers
how are you you mean the guy who's in
all the newspapers and all over TV Oh
nobody
what world these people live in or
villains can throw a Batarang at some
random actress and that makes enough
sense to the cops to believe Batman did
it also luckily for Catwoman's plan one
of the Penguins goons kept the Batarang
he threw at them in the last battle
otherwise how the hell they going to
frame Batman for anything and one
denmoor that's pretty much the
explanation the movie gives for why
Vicki Vale isn't in Batman Returns but
let's face it the real reason is it's
always more entertaining to have some
new love interests than to keep the one
who's so goddamn special in the last
movie this is purely circumstantial and
by no means should be shown on
television for any reason but it's great
for the half-baked villainous plan Bruce
and selina were just about to have sex
on the couch when Alfred comes wandering
out of this room without being called or
anything so how many times has Alfred
seen Bruce rogering a lady in the
mansion 52 microphones but only WX rx
was allowed to use a branded mic for
this event
fishing also at what point did the
circus gang learn enough about the
Batmobile to build a remote that it
would obey but just because you show me
that they have some ill-gotten
blueprints doesn't explain how they
built a remote that cracks all the cars
security features look I know penguin
wants to make it so that it's easy for
Batman to find this actress but this is
still one of the luckiest found a kidnap
person in a huge city moments I've ever
seen absolutely no one is around to
witness this gang thing with the
Batmobile it feels like at this point
that Batman should know Catwoman -
Selina Kyle greatest detective in the
world sure but can't see the uncanny
resemblance between alter egos Batman
pushed the princess listening a random
in the ground you did not see from down
here you see how far up this is and how
dark it is and you're making this casual
accusation while the woman is in midair
mistletoe can be deadly if you eat it
mmm but a kiss can be even deadlier if
you mean it
there's no reason for Batman to even
bother saying this silly phrase in this
situation other than the scene later
when they find out each other secret
identities also after the cops world
record speed and getting to the top of
that one building they apparently lost
all ability to track and chase Batman
after he fell onto another one but with
the buildings the way they are in this
movie who knows what's possible what's
not movie accidentally makes me think
this is what kissing is leading to a
world record embarrassing first kiss
encounter oh yeah he has wings I
couldn't save that girl from falling a
minute ago or at least try all that
bullsh just happens to wrap-up at the
exact time Batman's coming back to get
his car I'm still shocked this movie
thinks the Batmobile is this easily
hackable among this movie's many sense
that people have Gotham rallying behind
Oswald as a mayoral candidate maybe the
most egregious
I just don't get the timing of all the
penguin was on top of a roof making
advances accountant and not particularly
concerned about time at all but he
somehow gets downstairs to put the
Batmobile before Batman can even reach
it did they custom build this thing I
mean I know he's about to control the
real Batmobile but did they need to make
the control system one of those nickel
horsey rides I
site Kmart penguin is rocking all over
the place while the real Batmobile is on
a level Street you mean you have this
kind of scanner but you don't have any
alarms that pop up when someone click
the car in the first place and knowing
the circus gang had the blueprints for
this car
why weren't all the manual functions
disabled so Batman couldn't operate
anything on the inside this is basically
an architectural ex market oh really
and it oh my god I had no idea the
Batmobile had a skinny mode ex machina
to security who lit the covere under the
Batcave Batman would be amazing at
cinema since that man CD player of
course has a bat symbol on it because
logos and marketing are important deep
down in a secret Batcave damn this crowd
brought a lot of lettuce and tomatoes
with them to this heretofore Pro Oswald
rally why is there only someone who
brings aizen's operated toys eh it
wasn't just someone it was everyone
thanks reverse Elephant Man reference
and by that I mean I hate it these are
the names of the firstborn sons of
Gotham City this movie is the Moses
story only Moses grows up to be the
Pharaoh I don't know how this really
just allegory really fits a comic book
sequel with more sexual innuendo than a
Russ Meyer film but whatever it's art
and stuff you take a car costume so
Selena and Bruce who both wear costumes
in the real world show up to this
costume party without a costume the
irony is thick but I'm still kicking you
out for not following the rules on the
invitation tickets this mistletoe is
hung in such a way that everyone at this
party should be making out right now no
mistletoe can be deadly if you eat it
Jesus Bruce that's a rookie ass move man
that's God's eye
I don't even know what to call this is
this a sudden realization of alter-ego
love connection bill and coincidence ex
machina cuz I think it might be movie
does nothing to explain penguins
obsession with yellow duckies also he
somehow had time to build a lift so
powerful we crashed through the
building's floor
not to mention destruction proofing this
ducky already find all the time all the
firstborn sons in Gotham are kids with
no mix of teenagers or adults my dear
and now because he's called penguin he
will be able to communicate with and
control actual penguins and I'm having
ant-man flashbacks all the sudden the
Penguins are moving above-ground you're
acting like you knew this would happen
and what the Penguins plan is you don't
remember all Batman knew was penguin
planning to kill everyone's firstborn
sons he did not know about the masked
penguin missile gathering and they're
gonna stop this by jamming the Penguins
frequencies something they should have
zero clue about since this is a plan
penguin just came up with weaponized
Penguins penguin army approaching launch
destination he had time to hire this
putting announcer girl to stare at some
live-action data stream and make
announcements Gil movie what penguin
shape radar images give me a fuckin
break wait does this watercraft fly -
how does he execute a barrel roll in a
sewer with this thing if this thing has
a duck image on it fine I just want to
know why it doesn't image all the other
objects in the room somehow the penguin
presents some kind of physical challenge
to Batman
why does penguin even press this button
what does he think will happen since the
penguin missiles are all right here also
Batman seems very lucky not to be
anywhere near the missiles as they
randomly find targets around penguins
lair Catwoman shows up in the finale so
that her character doesn't seem
worthless and that fails shut up you're
going to jail for what what in this
movie can you actually pin on Mac Shrek
yeah we all know he's dirty but evidence
of what crime does Batman have on it
meaningless explosions a bear statue
Falls excitement what is the purpose of
this she already knows Bruce's Batman
because of the mistletoe the only thing
this does is tell max who Batman is
don't bother aiming for the head dick
face this movie has no idea how to end
itself so it just took all the ideas
from the brainstorming meeting and
implemented them in one big screwball of
an ending penguin pallbearers and
funeral rituals and there were many many
more adventures with Batman and Catwoman
after this
chicks dig the car
time after being perched atop their
mothers feet for a thousand paces like a
child learning to dance on her mother's
shoes
mr. Chou now pucker up please I can't
digest milk your son can stretch as far
as you can without injuring yourself
he's a symbol no we don't have to be
afraid of scum like you yeah you do
Brian
you really do you're a deep of the wrong
people you don't get to judge me just
because you were born in the master
bedroom of women actually I was born in
the Regency